he's been a good governor and I think
that you know I'm a fan of Governors I
think Governors know what it means to
run something they understand how to
deal with a crisis they understand how
to deal with the budget there's a lot to
be said about a governor you know the
only thing I'll say is that you know
watching him
like
he took a did a total 180 and switched
on where he was on entitlements and is
now where Trump is he did a total 180 on
where he is with Ukraine and is now
where Trump is so it just comes across
like a trump Echo well you know then
there's no difference between the two of
them
I use the socialness and quote on the
show every day all we have to do is stop
participating in the lie that's it but
it seems like everyone is lying all I
mean that's basically all I do every
morning I'm like all right who lied
today let's go through 20 people that
just can't tell the truth will that in a
way be the hardest part of running for
president that you know no matter what
you say and any any of you guys on this
side of the aisle they're basically
going to make it up and you got to just
keep slogging through that no I mean
that's part of it you know politics is a
blood sport you don't get in if you
can't you know take the heat yes they're
going to cut things up yes they're going
to tell lies yes they're going to say
things that's already happened that's
happened you know throughout my
political life but my job is to just
keep communicating what I believe what
my truth is there's rumors out there
about all kinds of things like what I
believe on this issue or that issue I'll
just you know I'll clearly tell you what
it is and then people realize I mean is
there something that you think is like
the biggest miscommunication about you
or something that oh I think it's I
think most recently the funny thing is
that um yeah that CNN did this article
and said oh she wants to cut off you
know Social Security and Medicare and
the truth is yes we do have to do entire
and that's what I said I said you if
you're going to be honest
you know yes we claw back the 500 yes we
go after the 100 fraud yes we stop
borrowing yes we cut the spending yes we
cut the earmarks but you have to talk
about entitlement reform and the way you
talk about it is we don't take from
anybody that was promised don't touch
seniors don't touch anyone that has put
money in that has been promised my
parents are in their 80s I don't want
anybody taking from them but my kids are
in their 20s and you go to them and you
say the game has changed for you because
they know they're not going to get it
anyway let's start there start with
everyone in their 20s coming into the
system and let's let's do a few things
one let's raise their retirement age so
that we actually are looking more at
life expectancy let's go and change cost
of living to relate more to inflation
instead of just a cost of living let's
go and let's make sure we expand
Medicare Advantage plans so you have
more competition you run down costs
those are the things that we could do
that would really make a difference if
we did that let's go and limit the
benefits that go to the wealthy because
you can talk to people like Bernie
markets they'll tell you I don't want it
but let's go ahead and limit that so you
know these are truths that we have to
acknowledge don't run from it because of
what CNN says just go out there and
educate on why you think what you think
so I want to get into some of the people
you'll be running against on the
Republican side but to quickly kind of
do the Democrat thing I mean is it a bit
of an odd thing that you kind of don't
know who you're running against because
your point it's like Biden has this
really been like what is going on there
I mean what what do you really make of
what's happening with him and who's in
charge and all that I mean look I I
think that you know it's easy to know
that Susan Rice is still in that white
house and that the old Obama crew is
still there but Biden has done an
amazing job at becoming much more
Progressive I mean than anybody ever
thought he would be I think you're
looking at Biden and Kamala that's who
we're looking at that's what you have to
assume if Biden isn't still there Kamala
is going to be the one in there and I'm
not okay with any of that yeah it'd be
kind of fun to run against her I feel
like that would be at least a little
more fun for you like the Biden thing
it's like how do you make sense I mean
that's fun too because you look at I
mean when you've got such a low bar I
mean that's not a bad thing so all right
so let's talk about some of the the
people that you'll be running against on
the Republican side because everyone I
think is trying to jockey for you know
what separates us all on these things so
first off I mean you could be on a
debate stage with your former boss
um do you Relish in that do you do you
you know I mean that seems to be where
he shines like what do you make of
having to do that I shine on a debate
stage too I mean it's just a fact you
know we're both running we're both going
to be on a debate stage he's my friend
but you know at the end of the day do we
have different styles in different ways
yeah I think that's going to show
and what about the guy here in Florida I
live in Florida now my life is
immeasurably better as you know because
of that like to me he's done basically
everything right we don't know if he's
running
um it sounds like there'll be a little
bit of a foreign policy difference with
you guys according to the Tucker thing
for sure but a lot of the other stuff
kind of seems similar what do you make
of that um well I saw your statement
actually you just put out a statement
that basically he's copying Trump on a
lot of this stuff I mean he's been a
good governor and I think that you know
I'm a fan of Governors I think Governors
know what it means to run something they
understand how to deal with a crisis
they understand how to deal with a
budget there's a lot to be said about a
governor you know the only thing I'll
say is that you know watching him
like he took a did a total 180 and
switched on where he was on entitlements
and is now where Trump is he did a total
180 on where he is with Ukraine and is
now where the Trump is so it just comes
across like a trump Echo well you know
then there's no difference between the
two of them could some of that just be
being in office and how things change I
I'm not going to assume to know what
he's thinking why he's thinking it I
just think that it's odd that he is
literally saying the exact same things
as Trump I mean you see like the same
things are coming out and I think
Americans when they look at it that were
the case they just vote for Trump
they're not looking for an Echo they're
looking for like
for for options but you know he's got to
decide where he's going to be on
everything I think you have to be honest
with the American people and say yes
you've got to acknowledge entitlement
reforms but there's a way to do it I
think you've got to be honest on you
know foreign policy that look if you are
going to be weak in the knees on Russia
you're going to end up with Russia being
just like China we've watched that have
we had Republicans and Democrats that
got weak in the knees on China and said
oh just leave them if we're nice to them
they'll want to be like us that is why
we are in this situation where they are
stealing intellectual property they're
now in our universities they're buying
up our Farmland they're sending spy
balloons up in the air it all started
with people saying you don't need to
worry about time let's just worry about
us well you start doing that with Russia
and now you're going to have China and
Russia there so actually instead of with
our remaining time going through the the
laundry list of people that are running
I think those are the big two so your
feelings are clear on that I just want
to ask you sort of philosophically I
think one of the things that I'm seeing
Bubble Up Now constantly is that the
people feel that the machine itself that
the the way the United States was
constructed cannot work at a federal
level that the states are so out of
whack with each other and that I fled
California that I I truly see no hope
for after the last time I was in San
Francisco I mean it is it barely looks
like an American city it looks like a
third world country basically and then I
see how things are flourishing here that
there really is a feeling amongst a
certain set of people on the right like
actually the the United part of this
thing is not going to work anymore and
that we should only focus on the states
what do you what do you think about that
I'm a state's rights girl you know I
mean I think that
you know as a governor I think that the
majority of control should always be in
the states I mean look the federal
government it breaks more than it fixes
we see that every day so you know as
president my goal is going to be to
empower the states as much as possible
whether it's health care whether it's
education whether it's military whether
it's all of those things it's best when
it's closest to the people that's when
government runs the best when you have
these Behemoth agencies that get so
bloated and so big and then try and
dictate to everybody what they should do
I think that's part of the problem we've
got to clean it out if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
mindless dribble check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell